don't worry i'm not going to go on
saying good morning in
a dozen or so languages
rather i would like to salute you first
of all on this initiative
which is gathering steam from the first
event in budapest
uh
a gathering of polyglots
and i want to talk a bit about what
being a polyglot means to me
uh i think it doesn't matter whether we
speak two or three languages or 15 or 20
or 40.
it doesn't matter if we are dilatants in
our approach in other words we just have
a superficial grasp of a large number of
languages
or whether we are perfectionists
and achieve a very high level in
perhaps a more limited number of
languages although
many of you there are extremely
proficient in quite a large number of
languages but none of that really
matters
what matters is the enjoyment the
enjoyment that we derive from
discovering new languages which is a joy
in itself discovering how these
different languages work
discovering similarities differences
uh compared to languages that we already
know
and then the enjoyment
of revisiting these languages because
obviously if we've got like in my case
i'm working i don't know 14 or 15.
uh when i revisit one of my old friends
it's always a pleasure
right now i'm working on ukrainian and
of course my friends russian
and czech
helped me and i know that
polish is not very far away
but i'm going to be meeting some koreans
later on today so i go back and refresh
my korean
and korean has a different melody and a
different way of putting thoughts
together and it's always a pleasure
to go back there and and i don't find
that i slip very much i just
i'm a little bit rusty and i discover
rediscover the language and i bring it
back up to the level it was and perhaps
a little bit beyond that and then i'm
able to enjoy the language in
interacting with people or perhaps in in
reading or listening or watching movies
or television so the joys are enormous
and everyone finds their own
way of enjoying the language their own
way of of enjoying learning the language
and so that's really
to me the importance of being a polyglot
it's not to demonstrate that we have
more languages are are better in
language a than language b the only
thing that matters is our enjoyment of
the language and so on that
on that note i would like to say you
know i wish you a very successful
conference
if you ever have a conference
uh in an area that's on the same
continent as i happen to be whether here
at home in north america or in europe i
will definitely make an effort to be
there
so uh zai jian adios
uh
arrivederci and uh whatever
good luck on the conference bye for now